everybody finds 41% of Americans use the
holidays as an excuse to postpone
getting in a good routine New York Times
bestselling author James clear wrote the
book atomic habits an easy and proven
way to build good habits and break bad
ones and he's here to help us make he
seems clear I don't I don't want to
pressure anybody to make healthy choices
but if one would like to what's your
advice to help them on their journey
sure yeah I think that's a good framing
- you know like it's not our job to try
to change people's behavior you can
decide but assuming that you want to do
something more healthier more productive
a lot of people feel like when the
holidays creep in they don't get to
maintain the healthy routines they
usually have so first thing I like to
recommend is reduce the scope but stick
to the schedule
so you're swell your schedule is how
frequently you perform the habit right
but the scope might mean while we're
traveling I can't try I can't workout
for the normal full hour could do one
pushup
one sit-up sounds like not much but the
goal actually here is not to transform
your body it's to cast a vote for I'm
the type of person who doesn't miss
workouts right it still like reinforced
this kind of stay in the game exactly
yeah I'd like your your home court
versus a weight court yeah plain please
just so this is an idea I heard from
Daria Rose she's a neuroscientist and
food blogger and she describes us as
having home-court habits in a way
courthouse so your home court habits are
the habits that you do when you're in
your normal work or home environment and
your way Court is when you're traveling
or on the road or at a family's house
for that's alright so what do you do the
way court is tough because you don't
control the space as much yeah so I
actually think ironically or
paradoxically the place to focus first
is to optimize the home court because
that's where you spend most of your time
and then if you zoom out you know over
the course of the year you might have 10
days that you're you know Christmas
Christmas Eve Thanksgiving New Year's
Day that are upsetting and you're like
in the away court environment so focus
on the home court first let the aware
you nearly half of Americans will say
they'll break their diet during the
holiday season Toni's putting butter on
top
[Laughter]
how do you find balance when all of this
holiday temptation is in front of you
yeah it's a good question there's a
concept that talked about in the Tommy
Capps I call environment design yeah and
I was speaking with Gail about this
earlier basically you could take like
the leftovers it sounds like a silly
small thing yeah but the unhealthy ones
you can put them in aluminum foil or
something that you don't can't see
through the healthy ones you can put
them in like Saran wraps but what about
my sensory radar for sure I think it's
useful about it even though it sounds
simple is that the larger concept is
that you want the good uses of your time
the productive habits to be easy to see
readily visible available and obvious
and you want the things that are bad
habits to be more steps between you and
them invisible hard to see greater
friction
you know never missed twice what's that
I thought that so never miss twice it's
basically saying look you may fall off
course you may have one meal that you
don't know you may have you may skip a
workout yeah I wish that hadn't happened
but never miss twice so let me make sure
the next meal is a healthy one or the
next day I get to work out in no don't
beat yourself up about the last one
focus on the next sure focus on the next
action yeah because if you beat yourself
up about the last one well yeah it's
over you just beat that's all yeah it
hurts slapping your own self in the face
it sure that's thank you thanks Jay